[Music]  open spaces average streets connectivity  a place to work your own personal  sanctuary four out of five women have  experienced harassment on the street one  out of three women have been affected by  sexual or physical violence one out of  five young women have suffered cyber  violence  one out of two women have dealt with  sexual harassment in the workplace  one out of two of all female murders  happen at the hands of an intimate  partner violence against women comes in  many forms the Istanbul convention  combats violence against women by  preventing violence protecting victims  and prosecuting the perpetrators  [Music]  the Istanbul convention must be ratified  and implemented by all governments to  stop violence against women